the biggest American problem the thing
would probably improve civilization of
people's experience of it the most is if
we were able to somehow encourage a
belief structure which did not equate
money and volume with value because
really almost every decision about
what's worthwhile in this country has to
do with its economic power and it would
be very amazing if so perhaps over some
it would have to be it would have to be
relief structures that would be changing
we begin to think that we were making
our own decision about what's valuable
and if it's not earning a lot of money
it may not be useless or worthless
obviously that's the perspective of the
artist I mean the artist is saying I
can't I can't compete at the level of
economic heft but what I'm offering is
something that will make your life
richer and maybe that's always a
minority view but I guess what I would I
would consider to be an ideal universe
would be a universe in which everyone
has spent part of the day reading a poem
or you know building something on their
house they think is beautiful a society
in which everyone's contribution to it
was to make their corner more of an
aesthetic experience and I think the
only society that's actually achieved
that informally partly because it kind
of an innate heat ism and partly because
of talent this problem is the is the
many many centuries from roman of italy
where every house seems to in a little
town seems to have been made part of a
composite